this man won two Super Bowls and now
he's in the Monday Night Football booth
and it's gonna be a lot of memory lane
tonight because this is the NFL 100 game
of the week each week the NFL is
designated an NFL 100 game of the week
for its historical significance and this
is a rematch of the same teams that
played in the very first Monday Night
Football game on September 20th 1970 and
on Monday September 16th 2019 big game
between the Browns and the Jets so
booger MacFarlane kind enough to call
into the rich eyes and show I believe
for the first time how you doing booger
I'm doing great rich this is the first
time I appreciate you have me and
hopefully it's not the last no it will
not be I am I've got a napkin tucked
into my shirt and a fork and a knife for
this piece of filet mignon tonight
booger
how in the world do you think in the
Jets pull this one off with Sam Donald
at home quarantined well I think they're
gonna have to slow the tempo of the game
down
I think Cleveland is a fast paced
offense as we saw last week just kind of
see they took the opening drive down the
hill they scored and always well and
then quote-unquote all hell broke loose
because they started committing
penalties late in the fourth quarter
Baker was pressing they turn the
football over
I think it's you're a Jets fan and you
got to have confidence that Trevor
siemian went back and watch the tape
around Donald Sam Donald iddin play well
last week Richard and I've been
similarly being a veteran quarterback he
started 24 games
I think the moment gonna be too big for
him he's got living on bail Demaryius
Thomas comes over a bit for a from the
New England Patriots Jameson Crowder
played well last week so he's got some
weapons I think the big thing for him is
just to try to let the game come to him
and try to slow the tempo of the game
down run lay beyond early not not
necessarily milk the clock but don't be
in a hurry because you want this Browns
offense to kind of feel like they're
pressing a little bit and how you do
that is you keep them on the sidelines
well and then you've obviously have CJ
Mosley out for the Jets as well with
Quinn and Williams in this offense from
the Browns coming at you what went wrong
for the Browns and all the film that
you've watched against the Titans bulgar
well I think the quarterback was
pressing a little bit you know they can
say what they want to say but you can
definitely tell that after the first
drive they thought man it's gonna be
easier this year we
absolutely no Super Bowl first drive
this season and they want to score every
place evening and to me that's an issue
because the National Football League is
built on a lot of good players
I think Baker made feel and also Freddie
kitchens they were pressing a little bit
instead of calling the slant route or
the run play they were trying to get the
15 20 yards chunk pass every time and
Tennessee just got to drop back and play
cover to and kept everything in front of
them and didn't allow too many big plays
and they became impatient but the bottom
line is they're offensive line also was
terrible I thought Chris Hubbard the
right tackle went to left tackle
when Robinson got kicked out he may I
mean he may have played the worst
offensive line that I've ever seen and
they got to get that shored up Freddie
told us yesterday that he's looking
forward to the game tonight because he
wants to find out what his team is made
of he's got a young football team that's
very very talented and when you have
young players you have an idea of how
they're going to react to perform but
you just don't know especially on Monday
Night Football with all the bells and
whistles that come with that I think
we're going to find out whether or not
this young team can handle the
expectations on a big stage in New York
it's gonna be a fun night 18 penalties
booger also didn't help and you mention
Greg Robinson getting kicked out of a
game I mean a left tackle getting kicked
out of a game because he kicked Kenny
Vaccaro in the head and and the loss of
composure that we saw from time to time
was alarming and now here comes as you
mentioned Monday Night Football MetLife
Stadium and Odell has already been out
there talking about Greg Williams and
Greg Williams returning fire how much do
you think that's going to play into
tonight's game are they gonna be good
for us you know we TV will have
something Jesus and let him talk no but
I'm just talking about what what Greg
might do to dial it up or the players in
Odell's face trying to trigger him or
Odell trying not to be triggered I mean
that's the sort of stuff huh I'm fully
aware you guys are definitely going to
be talking about this is what rightfully
so right I think you know I think the
play is gonna bring that's what players
do on the field some talks on dog
whatever your prerogative is I don't
know if Greg can dial it up the way they
were used to Greg Williams doing that
because the court
bucks for the Jets Roberts and Tremaine
Johnson didn't play well either and so
if you're great but you really want to
leave your corners on all alone one
where they didn't play well against the
Buffalo Bills who I probably can't even
name one of their receivers and now
you're going up against obj and Jarvis
Landry and David and Joe cool and make
sure like the weapons that you're going
to see tonight are going to be two times
the weapons you saw against Tennessee
excuse me against Buffalo and they
didn't play well against Buffalo so I
think Gregg is going to try to play to
the running game and try to keep this
game close
you're a Jets fan and into the first
quarter and it's 73 or it's 10 7 or 10 3
you got to feel pretty good what you do
not want is that the first quarter this
game is 14 nothing because that means
that that offense it's half line and now
miles Garrett Olivia burning and show
the Richardson can get up to Trevor
Simeon which is what you do not want
Berger McFarland from Monday Night
Football here on the Rich Eisen show how
quickly are we going to see Adele's
watch on your broadcast tonight do you
think [ __ ] you know I think it's going
to be at some point early on J Rothman
our producer does a great job you know I
can't stay in my light I things that I
need to know I know things that I don't
I really don't worry about so I'm sure
he'll put it on the screen at some point
it's presley Bodell has a big pitcher
Lee I mean that's part of the story
lines we got Lisa Salters we've done a
great job and I'm sure she'll have
something on it but you're not it goes
rich I mean it's a national broadcast
we're going to introduce people to the
big topics of the last week involving
these two teams and that definitely has
been one why is that one do you think do
you think it's because if it's Odell or
just it's the how expensive the watch is
or do we do we get bored as a national
media talking about stuff between Monday
and Wednesday how big of a deal do you
think this really is booger I think
anytime Odell Beckham who is box-office
he is a star any time you said something
does something that isn't in any way
shape or form into the controversy so
we're going to jump all over because
that's going to get people to pay
attention as long as it's legal by NFL
rules I could care less if it's illegal
then okay you got to take it off and
let's move on and I think people are
enamored because of this rich how many
people would wear
I own a $200,000 watch and be would you
read during a game or during a battle or
a competition and you know I think
there's a portion of American I just
didn't understand that mindset because
they've never been in it they're never
only kind of watching or if they were
able to own it would they put that watch
in competition I think all those things
doctor in but Oh Dale is coming back to
New York whatever he said this week was
going to be a big story so the watch
this fits right in well the big news of
the day going in is Ben Roethlisberger
being done for the year
obviously the Browns need a win tonight
to stay within hailing distance of the
Ravens just two weeks in do you think
this ends the Steelers season question
one on this program very difficult I
like Mason Rudolph I don't love him you
know the Steelers were always going to
have to be an offensive team because the
defense is still getting used to plan
you know with Devon Bush at the middle
of the spod and you know the secondary
has been an issue for a couple of years
they gave up three yards of Russell
Wilson yesterday so they were gonna have
to help score people now that becomes a
lot more difficult not that Mason
Rudolph is not capable but he just
doesn't have the moxie nor the
experience that there are office product
does so I don't want to say their season
is over because Mike Tomlin I think when
you talk about the handful of coaches
that are among the elite in the National
Football League he's right up there and
I know some people don't like that but
his track record was proven and I have
faith in my tournament he's going to
rally the troops they don't have to
figure out a different way to play but
it's going to be very difficult for them
to compete with the likes of Kansas City
in New England now that they're Super
Bowl winning quarterback is no longer
available I'm with you two on Tomlin I
mean the number of people that think
that he should eat it
based on the fact that Brown and Bell
are not there anymore that he didn't
make it all work and I'm like there was
an iceberg we only saw the tip of it III
I'm just not here for all the Tomlin hey
booger flat out I don't understand
the amount of people around America that
when they mentioned Bill Belichick and
then you start to think about who's the
next winningest coach
the National Football League over the
last several years who's the guy that's
never had a losing season they don't
mention my tumblr but like those are his
credentials and I just think that he
deserves a little bit more respect not
from just national media but the people
who actually quote-unquote know this
game he just doesn't get his just do and
to me that's not right but he'll never
say it I got no mic personally he was on
our staff in Tampa and you know I
watched him go from position coach the
defensive coordinator to now and one of
the longest tenured head coaches in the
National Football League and everything
he's got in his arm because of what he's
done on a football field and so I just
don't get that that narrative around the
country well the first hour after Big
Ben's retirement in the first blush
narrative about retirement
injury and first blush narrative was
involving retirement about Big Ben that
this could be it you know knowing him as
you do or covering him as you have and
knowing what people think of Big Ben as
well do you think that he is that this
could be it he's having Tommy John
surgery it appears here better
physically he's capable of playing I
fully expect him to come back and I
think with the advances in medicine you
know you see guys can attack in baseball
and they're throwing harder after
they've had the Tommy John surgery than
when they were before so I fully expect
the medical part to be there Ben
Roethlisberger is a competitor
regardless of what he says in the
attention that he tries to get he's
always a God has shown up in play and I
think that as long as the medical piece
checks out I fully expect him to be back
next year and it doesn't mean if you're
not gonna get the dog-and-pony show
because being like a kitchenette dan
loves his attention so he may fear
comments and get people to thinking he's
gonna retire but I think come next July
being Roethlisberger will be in Latrobe
and he'll be instead of scammin okay
that's the poll question - booger
McFarland Chris Brockman here on the
Rich Eisen show go for it hey booger
what - no team is the most surprising to
you 49ers Bills Packer Seahawks
that'll be the bills right I mean for me
the 49ers were my sleeper team I think
they're going to be dynamite especially
on jibiji settles in the Packers for as
much for as many headlines as we made
about audible gates and whether or not
Aaron Rodgers can Oliver or not I mean
this their defense that's really playing
well the Big East entailed Minnesota
the 16 points now I realize Kirk Cousins
help them out with some some terrible
decision-making in number ago line but
how could it not be the bills because
they're stuck up their way in New York
almost in Canada nobody thinks about
coach arming their army jockey Alan he's
just an athlete playing quarterback what
do we really know about them well right
now we know that they're they're a good
football team they're playing with good
fundamentals there too and oh the
quarterback is making plays within
himself he's not trying to be breeze or
Brady he's using his legs he's running
around and so I think right now you got
to feel really good about now do I
expect the bills to be there in the end
no can they compete if they're clicking
on all cylinders with Kansas City and
New England no but I'll tell you what Oh
to an OSHA field a lot better knowing to
it this time I know that yeah I know and
then you know Brees you mentioned him
we've got Teddy Bridgewater for the next
six weeks where do you place the Saints
once once Brees does in fact as expected
return Richard you know this when you
have a capable backup you're really
hoping for that guy that keeps you at
500 people float and the Bridgewater can
keep them you know if he's gone six
weeks if he can keep the Saints at three
and three even two and four what they
can't do is just lose every game because
I think when Drew Brees comes back we
all around the country have the Saints
pegged as a Super Bowl contender one of
the high contenders in the NFC and
throughout the league and as long as
breeze comes back healthy and the
defense is still pretty much healthy cam
Jordans the mario davis is where the
more underrated linebackers in football
number 56 watching he's fun to watch i
think the things are going to be right
there in the end because of the division
that they play in Jameis Winston doesn't
scare you Cam Newton looks like a shell
of himself
Matt Ryan I swear he was colorblind last
night I know who
was throwing the football to other
booties Julio Jones and other players so
that division is going to keep the same
I think in it regardless of who's
quarterbacking for them over the next
six weeks and then last one for you we
didn't include the Ravens in the
surprising to know teams because they
won the division last year but right the
conversation that I hear even though I'm
I'm I was in July aboard the Ravens and
Lamar Jackson trained well they did it
against the tanking Dolphins team well
the team that was first on the clock was
playing their first road game with their
rookie quarterback how real are the
Ravens in your mind booger well I think
the Ravens understand who they are they
have a really good business they have a
quarterback that can use his legs and he
is progressing by leaps and bounds as a
person I was a guy who was really not a
little more Jackson fan because I think
the quarterback position has to be
played from within the pot he
distributing the football to your
playmakers
I've been around football for a long
time which I've never seen a running
quarterback last a long time
and I've seen some great ones Michael
Vick rg3 they just don't last so far
Lamar Jackson's proven he can keep his
body in the pocket and throw the
football now I realized he rushed 127
yards yesterday he didn't thinking on he
rushed for three yards the first game so
he's trying to pick and choose when he
goes as long as he does that they can
sustain his stamina what he cannot do is
revert back to what he did at the end of
last year and I hope he doesn't because
it's a it's a pleasure to see the
progression you know you often hear
those same guys get better from year one
in year two
like this kid is really gotten better
this is not the same kid that we saw
complete three passes and Mister charges
and a playoff game and we were like
y'all sure y'all want to get rid of
Flacco now all of a sudden I mean people
are saying Lamar Jackson and they're
mentioning three letters that I thought
we never mentioned that didn't be peak
so it's been fun to see the defense is
really really good John Harbaugh is an
underrated coaches like Mike Tomlin
former special teams coach he does a
phenomenal job and you got to give a
shout out the eysie Newsome for moving
back in the first round and drafting
Lamar Jackson even when he knew he was
on the way out he still took the best
player available and set the franchise
up for this success so I think everybody
deserves a little credit the mother of
all farewell gifts from Ozzie Newsome as
you've walking out the door well well
well well pointed out bugger I look
forward to tonight's broadcast I will be
watching and look forward to the next
time calling in thanks rich appreciative
always a margin man you do a hell of a
job and more anything you make it fun
you keep it real and I think that's what
TV should be man so big big props to you
buddy thanks booger really appreciate it
I look forward to as I said the next
call and tonight on Monday Night
Football the NFL 100 game of the week
the Browns and the Jets in honor of the
50th anniversary for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app